ya un mois lorsque l'épicier le gremio
jt de tf1 on pensait vraiment que tu es
proche d'une réconciliation n'avait
parle également sur rtl et en fait on se
rend compte que maintenant c'est un pas
en avant deux pas en arrière on n'a
jamais été aussi loin c'est la guerre
totale et vous avez des infos catherine
rambert notamment à ce sujet là
absolument d'abord cette pseudo
réconciliation c'est un leurre vous
souvenez vous je n'y ai jamais cru
oui et bien naïf et et ceux qui ont cru
pourquoi ils ont jusqu'à présent david
et laura via leur avocat n'avait pas
bloqué les royals qui les albums les
royalties entre les revenus générés par
celui qui paye les revues de la musique
depuis la mort de johnny il ne voulait
pas à l'époque
asphyxié laura c'était la seule raison
les différences et laetitia par exemple
c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
n'ont pas fait ils ont découvert cet été
que ses revenus des royalties allait
peut-être être mis dans les trusts
américain s'est mis dans des trusts
américain cet inconfort c'est bloqué
c'est un coffre-fort dans lequel il faut
expliquer aux jours du coup c'est pour
laetitia les enfants métis la serbie le
cas aux états unis on peut y avoir ça ne
peut plus rentrer dans la succession
donc ils ont fait bloquer cette façon à
ce que ça rende à la succession
ils ont bloqué n'ont pas tous les royals
team et 75 % c'est-à-dire la part des
enfants
c'est pour ça qu'on a pris cette semaine
qui effectivement ils voulaient bloquer
tous les royalties du disque qui est un
énorme succès on va attendre et on va
attendre un milieu où nous arrivons mes
albums on à 115% pour ne pas bloquer la
part juste de laëtitia mais bloquer
celles d affreuse que ce qu'on avait
appris ces musiciens et vous me l'avez
c'est que en fait il ya eu un avaloir
tellement énorme sur le dernier album
qui est de l'ordre de 1 ou 2 millions là
aussi pour expliquer à valoir
johnny de son vivant qui a pris une
avance sur cet album donc déjà le
message général il a déjà pris deux
occasions et demi sur les deux millions
et demi donc ça déjà laetitia voilà
certainement c'est parce qu'on parle à
peu près de l'album devrait rapporter
entre 3 oz en dur de 3 millions d'euros
à laëtitia et effectivement johnny
aurait déjà touché en avance 1 million
et demi qu'il aurait déjà millions de
trust américain donc ça déjà c'est
d'ailleurs pour finir et brown que
mathieu ils ont juste réaliser que la
stratégie de communication de laëtitia
patel est venu vendre l'album de johnny
qui a laissé entendre qu'ils avaient un
pseudo arrangements c'était de la com
c'était du fake pour faire sa promotion
tranquille jamais été aussi d'ailleurs
pendant juste parce qu'il faut qu'on
avance et un petit bout il ya une phrase
dans closer je sais pas si vous l'a
confirmé cette vie humaine lulu pardon
c'est ccc selon closer al ahly dessus
aurait déclaré david et laura seront
asphyxié à vendre eux-mêmes ce qu'elle
dira si la guerre n'a jamais été aussi
sereine sur cette nouvelle attaque parce
que oui ça a fait bloquer les royalty
mais voilà de toucher un million et demi
d'avancé il ya un an et elle avait déjà
dans les trousses c'était beaucoup
d'argent comme on l'a montré les maisons
les marins absolue et elle n'est pas du
tout elle peut faire la gueule la guerre
judiciaire longtemps plus que laura
qu'est un peu plus fébriles au niveau de
la rue jusque là découverte aussi
également david oakes et deux maisons
une qui s'appelle jane qui s'appelle
jack et coûtera environ 5 millions
d'euros qui était à saint bar personne
ne connaissait l'existence aussi d'une
holding qui s'appelle mamour qui
pèserait 5 millions d'euros bref plus on
creuse on ne sait pas de lock on
découvre c'est du pétrole